all right we we have a man that wants to
get involved right now in the past
analysis the winner of uh today's round
dmitry gurevich is with us dimitri
welcome back to the show uh big victory
for you i wasn't hoping to be back
well you are and you are in uh
extraordinary fashion actually first
let's take a look at your game and then
we'll get to the analysis of that end
game as well so let's start with your
game tell us what were the critical
moments the critical moments was only
when he played f3 it was a critical
critical moment because nick never
played this move as far as i know he
always played bishop c4 and he was great
and he beat me a number of times i think
i beat him once or something uh and
he's there was one you know i loved
surgeon when i was when fisher started
playing people playing it i i really
liked so it's like many many young guys
at that time
and i played it for both colors
soldiers
f3 uh was a difficult move for me
because i always took on d4 and played
g6
i think i was lucky to beat lazaro
brazon years ago when he was world
junior champion when he wasn't it was
already good and uh it worked out and
then i kept doing it in low-rated
tournaments in terms of and it was
successful but uh it's not a good
position i think and and recently in
chicago and the kid also gardesi uh he's
low-rated but he's very very very
talented he
crashed me in that position so i thought
i'm not going to do it again i want to
but i didn't learn it properly i i knew
that
it's two moves is six so e5 i much
rather play e6 is my style but uh if i
was a better move probably more
you know reliable so so you decided to
go with a little objective precision
more or less so i i didn't study it as
enough yes usually you don't do enough
yeah so but i felt the position is okay
and then i remember a little bit i i
knew two great guys uh
i was working with victor kochen and i
was i can't even say that argentina was
friend of michelle thought because he
had thousand friends thousands of
friends so that was one of those i mean
and
in 1988 i saw
seven
times in four different countries so it
was very fortunate anyway once i know
that albeit correctional some line is
very late in life not in the beginning
with a5 bishop b5 knight a7 something
like that so it was something which i i
remember oh i'm thinking about two of my
favorite people to my favorite chess
players and i might even get to this
type of position so i it was okay it was
okay and then when he didn't do that i
thought well that gives me more chances
probably that i'm not sure i know that
nick also didn't not a big special in
this position but he's a great citizen
player so
i thought uh he's he's you know in
better shape but that was
the case so still the best thing you can
uh expect in this position i was very
happy with this position because
yeah i thought that this is it if if for
you know i thought if he doesn't take
i'm very happy if he plays bishop of two
i was going to play bishop g5 where is
all this kind of tactics for black so i
thought if she takes a pawn which i
expect yeah this is you for like g4
knight g3 something like this takes text
queen h4 so it looks good so
and uh usually i get this kind of
positions in kinzini and with white and
she have been a lot of trouble so you
know they said anyway so i was very
happy with this position because uh if
you can get something yeah this is it
because you have a square and one pawn
and you think you give you forget about
the pawn yeah if they pay the price they
don't mind i mean
this is at least i can play so at some
variation for example after bishop f6 uh
this is a line
uh uh after bishop of six he plays
bishop g6 that's the fourth sorry
oh yeah play bishop
something like queen b6 check c5 knight
take c5 so it's it's working for black
yeah so he played this move uh rook to
f1 let's keep going yes sir uh
you know i thought this is a black
what do you say rokofan no let's keep
going oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah no this is fine if bring the rock
okay to eat black
gold oh this is i didn't realize it's a
blunder right away i knew that my
passion is fine yes and then i as small
as i saw i couldn't believe it what is
that which one should be takes takes
queen of two yeah so so this is a bad
position it probably lost it doesn't
mean i'm going to win it
but objectively
it is
it is a
good position but i don't think you
relinquish the pressure at any moment in
this game went on to win well i know
that it's tactics for white if i do
something wrong as i usually did in the
past a lot of things oh you do you don't
make one mistake one little mistake yes
that's it situation changes you don't
have too much time and you blunder
happened to me millions of times so
you're still careful oh of course no
doubt about it but that's it you know
this is the moment i saw this variation
yeah i made twins you see just in case
one more one more move why not yeah yes
yes
and this i saw the end game because i
realized i might have something better
but i should be so fortunate to have
this so end game is supposed to be
winning and and then i thought i can do
this so you can do that i can go [ __ ]
ponentium some relations and why do i do
that because
sometimes it's that miracle draw
one of them it's all about the
calculation in those angles i am just
just teacher
and this skin ponegm there's some
miracle drawers and you don't don't
expect to do to win because you have
extra pawn yes this this happens but
this is a very good question for example
king f7 is one of those same games kind
of seven instead of king of six
and
rook
then
g3 f7 uh then rocked exterior g6
exchange and um
probably and this is winning position
i mean 99 19 but sometimes it's a draw
yes well nine ninety percent but who
care i mean i have one end game that's a
rock and a game so why should i uh even
uh think about because skin panel game
is easier no sometimes it's not kin for
nagins i told my students always it's
always some some a miracle thing you
never know what will happen and
it's always an adventure yes yes it's
very concrete you know that is you the
guy has a queen and he beats you no
matter who you are marcus carson
99
but two pawns in a rook and game well in
this position you know that was too much
rock and nan games
two points no guarantee yes
it happens in some positions especially
classical rock and my students just had
that rock and pawns
cna or
hnf
it is in between it's kind of positioned
uh which the top second top player in
the world paul kerry's hero the book
here but thinks this is a mistake so the
world champion says about the second or
third gold player that he makes mistake
in this thing but miss how complex it is
yeah i have my own stories
so but this is it's a one position yeah
dimitri uh a great result so far for you
you're getting closer to those
leadership positions how do you assess
your chances are you thinking about it
absolutely is it too early oh
it's not even
not even a question for me i have to
play uh three players and
i mean
two two players are legends you know one
is great player he's not professional
but he's also a very strong player so
i'm not even thinking about it well you
are a legend yourself as well so
keep the momentum keep the energy going
and we'll see you in the next few rounds
will be exciting for sure absolutely our
congratulations to you dima very very
nice thank you